In college, I had a chance to be a resident assistant, a rep in charge of fun
activities and events on a floor.
Well, to help us have some compassion and understanding for students on our floor
who might have handicaps, the leadership decided that we would go around for a day
with a handicap of sorts. And my handicap was to wear a blindfold.
It really dawned on me for the first time since I had to go to the cafeteria, I had
to go to class with this blindfold on, how tough it is to navigate life without
sight. Well, how did I cope? How did I make it through the day?
Well, I had to ask somebody to help me.
Who did I ask? I didn't ask a stranger.
I didn't ask somebody I just met.
I asked somebody I trusted, one of my basketball teammates, to help me out through
the day. People often have the idea that faith is blind.
And when it comes to issues of religion, it's like we're frolicking around in the
dark and basing our beliefs on sheer ignorance.
Well this might be true for some religions but it is not true for Christianity.
You see biblically faith is trusting what we have reason to believe is
true. Just as I followed the guidance of my friend whom I had good reason to
trust when I was blindfolded. God asks us to follow Him, and He's given us good
reasons to trust Him.
We are not called to blind faith.
We see a remarkable pattern in Exodus chapter 7 through 14.
God would do a powerful miracle through Moses, a sign which gave the people
knowledge of who God is. And as a result, He called them to believe in Him and
to place their trust in Him. So here's the pattern.
God would do a miracle through Moses.
This gave the people knowledge, and then they were called to belief.
Miracle, knowledge, belief. Consider an example.
In Exodus chapter 7 verse 17, Moses is about to do the miracle of turning the water,
the Nile, into blood. And it says, by this you shall know.
Now what is this? This is the miracle Moses was about to do.
and it says and you shall know because that miracle would give them knowledge
so Moses is doing this powerful miracle it gives them knowledge that the God of
Israel is the one true God and then they're called to belief so our pattern which is
clearly emerging is miracle knowledge and then belief
we see the same pattern in the New Testament in the Gospel of Mark Jesus
is in Capernaum and he's preaching in a home.
And four men bring a paralytic to him.
And they can't get into him, so they go up on the roof, remove the roof, and lower
this paralytic down to Jesus. And Jesus sees them as a result of their faith, says,
Son, your sins are forgiven. Now the scribes and Pharisees are thinking, wait a
minute, who can forgive sins but God alone?
This is blasphemy. What does Jesus do?
If you skip down and look at verse 10, it says this.
Jesus said so that you may know that the Son of Man has
authority on earth to forgive sins he looked at the paralytic he says rise pick up
your mat and go home Jesus did that sign as proof that gave
them knowledge of who he was and the implication was Jesus is the Son of God now
believe in him you might be thinking wait a minute, didn't Jesus do the
miracle because of the man's faith?
After all, it says in Mark chapter 2 that Jesus, seeing their faith pronounced to
the man, son, your sins are forgiven.
Now it is true that God often does reward our faith by performing miracles.
But let's ask a more basic question.
Why did these four men and the paralytic come to Jesus in the first place?
And the answer is because, as Mark 1 tells us, Jesus had already been performing
miracles. Jesus had already been casting out demons.
He had given them evidence and signs that he's the Son of God.
So they came to him with confidence and put a faith in him that was well placed.
Jesus calls people to love God with their heart, with their soul, with their
strength, and with their minds. In the Old Testament, God says through the prophet
Isaiah, come let us reason together.
In the Old Testament and in the New Testament, God calls people to an intelligent
faith and he still does the same today.
This is why in the Gospel of John, a gospel which is written recording the miracles
of Jesus and inviting people to a confident faith.
At the very end of the Gospel, John writes in chapter 20 verses 30 through 31
that Jesus has performed many other miracles not even recorded in this book.
But they've been recorded so we might have confidence that Jesus is the Son of God,
He's the Christ, and by believing in Him we may experience eternal life.
The Gospel of John is written so we understand who Jesus is based on the miracles
so we can have a confident faith and by having that faith experience eternal life.
Biblical faith is not blind. The Bible invites non-believers to
investigate the evidence, to consider the claims of Christ, and then to
consider believing in Him. And as Christians, we're also not called to a blind
faith. We are called to think deeply about our faith, to know why we believe what we
believe. We are called to have an answer when people ask us the reason for the hope
we have within.